you know i think everybody felt it
wasn't about football today i think
everyone had heavy hearts and everyone's
had really you know thoughts and and
conversation is there a sense of comfort
though being back and seeing everything
the team is doing to try to keep you
guys safe
i'm just like i said i'm just here to
play football um
no opinion or
answer to that question really i really
don't give a damn about that um
you know we can play in the stadium
that's full half full third full home or
away we're happy that shows progress
with the culvert otherwise we you know i
i personally don't care
okay other than i would like to see fans
baker said this week that
uh your chemistry
between the two of you is going to be
way better than it was last season do
you feel the same way and so why is that
um you know of course i'm going to say
it's going to be better than last year
but
again it's kind of a day by day approach
um and we'll see what happens when we
get out on the field as far as him he
looks great
[Music]
mentally
physically he's got like a four pack now
um so
he he's doing great man he's just saying
he's just in a good place and you know
as as a teammate and as a guy who's
always been a fan of bake as a brother
um it's great to see him in this place
so we're just working each and every day
we played that during pft live today but
we didn't have a chance to react to it
we wanted to start p-f-t-o-t
on this wednesday with those comments
from odell beckham jr about his
chemistry with baker mayfield because
chris and i both kind of paused when he
paused and when he said well of course
i'm going to say it's better
it really makes me wonder number one
chris how bad it was last year
and number two whether odell truly feels
it's going to be any different in 2020
just kind of listening between the lines
i don't get the impression that odell is
ready
to declare that there's going to be any
dramatic difference in their chemistry
from last year to this year well he
definitely seemed off in those snippets
of that interview right like not the
same
you know energy and exuberance we
usually see from odell beckham jr very
measured definitely and hey we've
discussed a lot you know on our show
throughout the last year
the connection was not good last year
between baker mayfield and odell beckham
jr i think baker mayfield felt the
pressure to get the ball to him you know
i think the whole organization you know
freddie kitchens everybody involved felt
that pressure i think it led to baker
mayfield
making some stupid decisions at times
and trying to force the ball to him and
really kind of confuse their offense to
a degree so i do expect it to get better
that that i do you know and yeah i think
he's in knowledge of that but to me more
than anything i just feel like he was
like um
and i've heard him say this to me before
and i've heard he i think he was being
very measured like he just he didn't
want to make any headlines and you know
i know on my podcast before he's
explained he gets exhausted how people
jump on every word and things he says
and hey i understand it rightly so he's
a superstar and you know he said some
things that deserve some attention every
now and then but yeah to me it was like
almost like a guy that was like gun shy
a little bit like uh i just i don't want
to do this i'm afraid of what i might
say so i'm going to just be really like
monotone and just answer every question
the same way and not really say anything
and see part of the maturation process
is first of all
not saying the things that people will
react to
and make you upset that they reacted to
the things you said the next level is
selling
when you say the thing that won't
trigger a reaction you got to do it in a
way that keeps us from saying
something's not right here yeah right
he's holding back something right and
this goes back to my initial reaction
march of 2019 when out of the blue the
giants trade beckham to the browns my
question is just as
baker mayfield is becoming the new
lebron james in cleveland based upon
what he did in his rookie season is the
town big enough for both of them and is
that playing out at some level beckham
and mayfield and who's got more sway in
the locker room and i'd love to know
what went on behind the scenes last year
when mayfield is regressing and there's
all this talk about beckham wants the
ball beckham wants the ball and how much
did that screw up baker when he's doing
his reads is he holding the ball too
long to give beckham a chance to get
open is he forcing the ball into
coverage when somebody else is open it
was that constant presence last year it
was of this question of we have to and
we were all over it because it's glaring
that's not how you run an offense here's
how you run an offense the quarterback
throws the ball to the guy who's open
that's right period right get open yeah
if you're not open and someone else is
you're helping the team win you're not
getting the stats so be it the team is
winning because there are favorable
matchups elsewhere because they're
determined to take you away and the more
that they talked about it chris these
coaches are smart they know the way to
beat the browns is take away otto
beckham jr and it's going to screw them
up because they're so determined to get
him the football yeah well there were
certain games where you knew that was
like the mantra going to the game let's
go to odell some touches early and do
you know force the ball to him make him
feel comfortable and get the offense
going that way and you're right that's
not the way to do it listen you when you
when you force a ball to the guy like
that yeah it throws off the whole rhythm
of the offense and more importantly
throws the psyche of the quarterback off
and and you know hey freddie kitchens is
partly to blame baker mayfield's partly
to blame for feeling that pressure he's
got to be able to be bigger than that
and block it out and just go like you're
saying i'm going to run the damn play
you know and i'm gonna read the coverage
and if it so happens to go to odell
beckham jr then so be it you know but
there was times where you know he forced
the ball he forced the wall i forced the
ball and you're like damn what is he
doing and then i think he gets in his
own head baker mayfield to where now
he's going wait i forced it to him too
many times let me go to the other side
of the field and then that's when you go
damn odell was open you should have
thrown it to him then now he's open he's
been open for the last four plays so
there was a lot of that inconsistency
going on last year kevin stefanski
yes don't go out of your way you can
formulate offensive attacks and game
plans around hey they were going to run
this drop back pass and i'm going to
make odell the first read but not to
where we're just going to go like oh
we're dropping back to pass and throwing
it to odell this play is just all about
him and getting him open no yeah you got
to do it by committee and you use that
guy as a pawn in your offense as a part
of your scheme to therefore then get
defenses to go wait their schemes pretty
good and man they know how to feed this
guy the ball in the scheme whoa we need
to do something to take away odell
beckham jr and then all of a sudden
jarvis landry's wide open or you know
david njoku or austin hooper and last
year they just had it a little bit
backwards and there certainly was
pressure on that situation
wait a minute you make austin hooper
your first pick in the best tight ends
draft other than travis kelsey and
george kittle and he gets mentioned
after david and joku i think you just
revealed yourself there you don't feel
as strongly about austin hooper as you
claimed i just had names going through
my head you know my brain it doesn't
always work coherently okay so and
here's the thing kevin stefanski was in
minnesota from 2006 through 2009. he got
there a couple of years after the failed
randy ratio but anytime there's a
receiver that a team is determined to
get the ball to that they've got this
personality that needs to be catered to
he needs to have the ball that's
counterproductive you can't do that you
can't say we're going to get the ball to
this player a certain number of times
defenses are too evolved now the
defensive backs are too good the
coverages are too good you can't force
the ball unless you truly have and even
a randy moss it doesn't work you can't
force the ball to the same guy over and
over and over again because that makes
your offense too predictable and it
creates too much stress when it doesn't
happen the way you want it to so
hopefully the browns are going to evolve
past that with kevin stevansky as the
head coach one last thing on beckham
you know we only played a little bit of
the conversation about whether he
considered opting out right because he
had the comments the wall street journal
a couple of weeks before camp opened
where he said hey i'd be fine if they
don't have a season at all i don't know
why we're even trying to do it he didn't
opt out he wouldn't talk about why and
whether he feels comfortable with the
team i think he wanted to stay away from
that topic altogether but i think his
words
made it obvious if he meant what he said
to the wall street journal he had to
have been thinking about opting out of
course yeah i think so you know i think
that it plays into what we were just
saying i just think he was gun shy in
this you know
right away and probably a little scarred
by yeah things that have happened before
and then yeah he makes those comments to
the wall street journal and it becomes a
big topic and i think he was afraid of
making news you know i do think he's a
guy that's you know again a superstar
but like you said he's maturing he's
trying to find his niche on this new
team and find his way to make it all
work and do those things and yeah it's
not always been perfect but i think he
let you know he's a guy that's a little
bit
wears his heart on his sleeve and it
gets him in trouble by doing that at
times and that's what kind of happened
with the wall street journal thing and
then he gets answered that by ask that
question there in cleveland yesterday
and i think he's just he's just going oh
damn i don't want to be on the cover of
the sports page here again in cleveland
tomorrow and have to answer these
questions and he just goes no comment
in buffalo josh allen has a different
mindset when it comes to running the
ball this year we noticed he was running
it less last year it sounds like he may
be running it even
on fewer occasions this year chris he
said to reporters on tuesday my mindset
this year is a little different i'm
trying to get the ball into our
playmakers hands and let them make plays
because they're a lot quicker and
shiftier than i am i don't know about
that based on how josh allen has run the
ball at times but when my number's
called i will step up to the plate um
look i i get it i understand it that's
what quarterback needs to do needs to
distribute the football but he has
significant skills when it comes to
running the ball and to the extent you
can use those skills to keep the defense
off balance you need to have that threat
and maybe this is part of the setup
right maybe they want people to think
he's not going to run the ball very much
but when you have those skills i'm not
saying overdo it but if the if you you
have to use those skills to have the
threat present and the threat needs to
be present to make it easier to operate
your passing game yeah that that's right
you know i i think you know
he's he's trying to be more of a
facilitator this year he does realize
that he's got weapons around him and he
doesn't have to do it all himself
but yes like to what you're saying mike
there's that fine line there where
well you're a great athlete and you can
do things with your leg that's not like
part of the reason we drafted you in the
top 10 is because of that so i i hope
what he's talking about is maybe a
little less game plan design runs you
know maybe himself
not lowering his shoulder like we saw
him doing the wild card game a number of
times and realizing wait the greater
good is not them for me to lower the
shoulder to get an extra yard it's for
me to be out here on the field playing
so uh hopefully he's understood that but
but you're right mike like i hope he
doesn't become a robot or a little too
much of a pocket pastor because some of
the great plays we've seen over the last
two years yeah not only in you know and
tell him like scra running but his
ability to scramble and buy extra time
and make unbelievable throws once he
escapes out of the pocket is one of his
greatest gifts uh so yeah hopefully
that's what he's talking about and just
not being maybe like the meat head you
know i'm you know the tough strong guy
great athlete on the field like i've
always been my whole life and starting
to realize whoa this is the nfl and i
could get hurt doing that crap
yeah whenever any quarterback runs the
ball he's got to run smart you can't put
your shoulder down you have to know when
to slide when to get out of bounds you
have to know how your body moves in
relation to the defenders that's one of
aaron rodgers great skills yeah same
thing with russell wilson russell wilson
and and i remember i remember stunning
him one time i i when he does i told him
he reminds me of barry sanders in that
barry sanders always had that instinct
where he knew exactly how to take a hit
yeah and you never saw barry sanders get
blown up right and you never see russell
wilson get blown up and we've seen josh
allen get blown up and we've seen him do
the blowing up and that's how you get
yourself injured as a quarterback uh
take it from robert griffin remember
that his first game with the brown
several years ago he decided to drop his
shoulder into i think it was the eagles
they were playing in cleveland that day
and the shoulder was injured and that
was that that was that robert griffin is
the starter the cleveland browns all
right robert griffin iii was drafted by
daniel snyder back in 2012 over the not
so subtle objection of the shanahans
daniel snyder
is on
twitter i was stunned to see this
yesterday chris
real underscore dan snyder there it is
and i have a pending request apparently
whoever took that screenshot has a
pending request too
he's got protected tweets you have to
request access so you click follow wow
and he'll decide at some point whether
or not he's going to let you
wow you his tweets whatever they may be
what do you think made the request
you're gonna make it
i you think he's gonna let me in i don't
think so no when i don't no i don't
think so i don't think so although here
this is the perfect litmus test or as
you once said on this program or on pft
live rather litanis test
if he really is changing if he really is
different he will let me in he will
right and why would he be on twitter if
this isn't a sign that he's changing
that he's different in some way now he
may find out very quickly that he wants
nothing to do with twitter i mean just
our simple story with the link saying
welcome to snyder or welcome to
schneider daniel twitter or welcome
twitter daniel schneider the con it's no
it's a cesspool yeah it is it is so i
don't know what either either he's a
sucker for punishment or uh he doesn't
quite understand how this works so far
he's following two accounts he's got
four followers you can't see any of that
unless he lets you follow him we'll see
you know one time
i clicked follow for le'veon bell and i
didn't realize his tweets were protected
and then i noticed like months after the
fact that it was still pending it's like
so i don't know i don't know when dan
snyder is going to get around to it it's
been a day now i'm waiting dan snyder
make a decision am i in or am i out and
chris i i suggest you do the same let's
see if one of us somehow gets in okay i
i like that i'm i'm down to do that i'm
going to do that when we get off the
show here i mean i i will echo the
sentiments of what you said i mean i
would hope this is a sign of like
him turning the page and him becoming a
different guy
and changing the aura around the
washington football team and everything
about that and maybe to give himself a
little bit of a voice because yeah for
lack of a better phrase he he kind of
been crapped on this off season so maybe
he feels like this is a a chance for him
to get some thoughts out there that will
help the team in the community and the
fan base to follow and do that and i got
no problem with that
i think he's gonna let you in you know
why why hold a special place in his
heart you are one of the few teams that
he actually beat in the playoffs during
his 21 years
in uh yeah you had to go there huh you
had to go there there's a connection
yeah there's connection connection that
still hurts me that still hurts me that
game damn you
we were better that day
don't you have to go do a radio
appearance or something
does it hurt you more than turning 40 in
three days what hurts more no yeah that
does that hurts more that hurts
definitely more i still have i i don't
really go by a week where i still don't
think about that every now and then and
go damn you know we won that we win that
game i don't know what happens that year
i mean we we had a chance to you know
maybe make a run it hurts
it's a great glimpse although i i'm
sorry that you have to deal with it it's
a great glimpse of how guys carry that
around for the rest of their lives long
after fans have forgotten about it and
moved on media has forgotten about it
and moved on for the guys who are in the
middle of it what may have been yeah
that's that nagging thing that never
goes away what could we have done if we
had gotten past that level right no
doubt i i got that once in my nfl career
and then once in my college career my
junior year we lost to colorado in the
big 12 championship if we win that game
we're gonna go play miami and the rose
bowl for the national championship those
two moments
uh they they yes come in my brain you
know every few weeks to where i go damn
if that if that was a little different
where would my life be what would have
happened what would our team have done
and uh yeah that's part of the greatness
of sports it really is
you probably would not be spending so
much time with a slappy like me
if that had worked out
you're right you're i i always tell
friends
that big 12 championship game i lost i
mean that that probably cost me 20
million dollars i mean i was thinking
about coming out in the draft as a
junior that year because i was having
people reach out to people around me
going you know we're thinking about
chris as the top 10 top 15 top 20 pick i
was literally deciding that then i threw
three interceptions in that big 12
championship game and there went that
dream flush it down the toilet
pete says we're glad you lost i say
speak for yourself
thank you pete
everybody have a great wednesday chris
let me let me be among the first to tell
you happy birthday coming up in three
days happy 40th we'll see everybody
tomorrow for another edition of pft live
have a great day see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports